alright guys goes on an animatic and
this is pretty much go vlog episode 3
bull c'mon go I think the guys know what
you know he's a pretty much go blow yeah
they know our channel they know our
channel anyways there's this event like
pokemon gold niagara is hosting an event
at secret garden by the falls and
apparently like a bunch of pokemon gold
players are coming from different parts
of Canada and it's gonna be sick I got
so we're here at the falls and you'll
see on screen about doors and gems here
and how many like learners without going
insane and it hasn't even started my log
houses started so
we're in for a good night hopefully no
rare sighting so far but we'll see
what's up four minutes to five guys all
right guys we're gonna show you some
awesome nature shots here The Secret
Garden really is beautiful and
everything new how how nice it is set up
so we're right in the middle of like the
biggest tourist area and agri falls
hotels everywhere and then you come into
this little spot and like a oasis I love
it like it literally it's making the me
forget about Pokemon because it's so
awesome but to be fair we've always seen
pages so sorry I'm 50 for EV bro yeah I
got a sec something yeah yeah well on
level 17 buddy I guess I guess I'll
catch it maybe
yes we ran up to some Pokemon fans here
what do you guys got to say what are
your levels I'm level 14 on level 10 15
0 18 coming along all right nice guys by
the way guys these guys weren't even
born yet when we were into full come on
just saying all right guys keep it up
this is junior he's the bait organizer
of the event myself I'm with our clifton
hill and we have a contest going on guys
want to be a part of that contest all
right basically the contest is you just
take on screen shots porcupines in front
of the interactions access the hill and
share that on our Facebook page if it's
a little Niagara Falls luggage so you
guys have any questions before you guys
head out yeah like if we photoshop i'm
you two in front of one of the things
and then attract a whole bunch of
business what do we get odor shopping in
description sure smedium you see there's
an immaculate some folk lon nothing good
gotta get enough nice vaporeon
we got Simon Garfunkel cover in the
background beautiful day looks like a
Flareon that I evi named Raynor yes
doesn't work all done what yeah I know I
had some dong dong dong glare well
dreams crushed that sucks that's why all
these strong
they also good man
all like
q collab music guys so it's my old
friend Vladimir is gone he pretty much
is a higher level than me i hate to
admit but I is 24 I just turned 23 and
we're gonna hear some advice from him so
if you want to be good at pokemon go you
got to follow some key steps number one
if your student or alumni skip school
you don't need that stuff number two if
you want to drive while playing pokemon
go excellent idea I do not walk walking
is for chumps disclaimer and uh I don't
even know what else just the trip
practice every day no time for
girlfriends girlfriend girlfriends are
not needed you want to be the best don't
you walk you a bit in here bro can I can
you can you show us your Pokemon oh yeah
sure it's got a little 36 people both of
those a little bit of both dragon age
here Jaya Michael or if you want to you
want to level up quick best thing to do
lures all the time and using eggs save
your eggs for evolve because 200 200
experience isn't that great when you're
catching a poke mom but popping stuff is
getting 500 getting 1,000 experience or
double there's no double as much fun as
you have the river that can be involved
until you like 30 or 40 above my stead
of lucky again
one of them at once make it six sixty
thousand one hundred thousand we didn't
happen out yeah like I did that once and
then i got lazy Kim yeah well this guy
doesn't like leave the house is like
ma'am I worked so hard but it's like you
don't even get out yeah you gotta be
consistent and he's got a battery pack
that will keep us both charged for like
ten so I gotta see these guys are port
fest this is the real deal can we can we
get a glitter tattoo though oh yeah sure
yeah look at this guy's their shirts do
that is a Pokemon master right that mr.
i represent 40 mystic take that oh yes
yes yes take that role Thank ma runner
on TV stick but Sheamus comes ants
thanks Scott hey guys we're here with
junior who organized this whole bull
from on diagram what one going are I've
been so JR tell us a bit about the event
and everything else going on I pretty
much just big meet up for everyone to
get long meet new people be some
teammates for their
same so the way yeah just to meet new
people and we can do more of these soon
if everything goes well today so far
it's a amazing turner so we're me a
great time right now and hopefully
there's more of these things but you
guys know and you want to talk about the
charity yeah so I'm taking donations for
the fort erie SPCA right now anything
over five dollars gets a bracelet
that'll really only be for today but you
guys can go to their website i'll post
it on Facebook me den whadda at the
length of the scripture video now i'll
post on there and you guys go that link
and donate with credit card or anything
or you can bring it to the shelter bring
some money or dog fence or anything
tonight yeah so while we're fighting
with fictional animals we want to
actually help ya real life really yeah
instead of abusing them in a good thing
and gay everyone out here for same jail
when everyone's wondering what level are
you I'm with all 18 oh hi yeah spent so
much time playing and they're like
helping nothing real out of luck just
want to reach 18 though so okay later
is level of 1,200 already f minus 40 90
shots fired
alright guys now we're recharging it
slower eating very healthy food so we're
charging our food our stomachs and our
batteries and then we'll go catch some
more pokemon and hey Wendy's sponsor us
so after a busy day of folk amounting
now we're gonna have some eggs crappy
van I already have to King low so I
don't really care about this but let's
keep going hopefully bolt another one
right away alright let's see what's it
gonna be huh growl with ma'am growling
meow ok that's cool we might have enough
for a Persian now yeah we have enough
for a Persian so it's gonna be a fun
evolution later on another one what's it
going to be another 5k guys
the duo you know I need to evolve it
eventually who cares all right let's
keep going see what else we're gonna get
all right guys 5k number four all right
fourth egg let's see what it's going to
be groundless come up
tentacool that's cool that's all right I
have attended cruel but it's cool let's
keep going it's another one it's cool
guys what a great pun I love my puns
another one let's go what do you think
it's gonna be an immac a growlithe
execute that's sick this might hit me
over yes one away I'll transfer one I
will be able to evolve and execute into
an executor that's gonna be fun and
that's one of the best full plank again
the game how strong is it CP this one
thought strong is the one I already had
so we're gonna actually transfer this
one and get the other cool so guys there
there's been another awesome day for
Pokemon catching and Pokemon golden agri
did a great job organizing this event it
was great meeting so many amazing
Pokemon trainers I personally got a
million pitches but also quite a few
poke one had actually needed I got
enough gas lease to get a gang gar and
then I'll force used to get a sidra also
my five kegs help me out get a Persian
and an executor which is definitely the
best pokemon i got today arcanine you're
next buddy anyways that's it for today's
video guys if you enjoyed this video
like it up and subscribe for new videos
until next time see you space cowboys
you